قال رئيس
ان بلاده لن تحصل على قروض جديده من الصين
على اساس المقابل النفطي واضاف في مقابله
مع برنامج للقصه بقيه والذي تقدمها زميله
فيروز زياني ان الحكومه تسعى لتصحيح هذا
النموذج
بدلا من الحديث عن فخ الديون مع الصين اود
القول ان شروط التمويل في ذلك الوقت لم
تكن الافضل لبلدنا لكن ذلك حل لمشكله
لاننا بهذا التمويل تمكنا من استعاده
البنى التحتيه الرئيسيه والطرق والجسور
والسكك الحديديه والموانئ وما الى ذلك لكن
الاتفاق لم يكن الافضل لنا لحقيقه انهم
حصلوا مقابل ذلك على النفط حيث استلموا
بشكل منتظم شحنات النفط الخام ونحن نحاول
تصحيح نموذج التمويل هذا لذا نحن لا
نتعاقد على ديون جديده مع الصين على اساس
المقابل النفطي